scp-096 the shy guy versus  scp-2599 the reality bender named xena  cho who comes out on top in a  confrontation between these two  incredibly powerful anomalies let's find  out  scp-2599 is a 14 year old girl who is  incapable of disobeying any command  given to her but also incapable of  successfully carrying out that command  fully she can come close but never quite  reach the goal she is given which can  allow for some powerful reality bending  in a test 2599 was told to neutralize  096 and she maneuvered and outwitted as  cp 096's frenzied rage state landing a  few hits on the entity but with 096  being as terrifyingly relentless as he  is 2599 only reached the halfway mark in  her execution she came incredibly close  to neutralizing the entity but in the  end her anomalous nature demands that  scp-096  undeniably comes out on top